[Music]
Let's see...
What'sthe next big thing after large language models?
The technology of large language models--which
is essentially, we could take a piece
of text, blank out some amount of it,
and then say what will the next word be, try and
predict it, learn if you get it wrong and then
just repeat over billions of times.
You can take a picture and blank
out bits of it and try to predict
what's in the part that's missing.
You can take a gene sequence and blank
out a piece of it and try and predict it.
So, this is then a very successful strategy
that can be used for all sorts of other
domains of human experience and science.
So we're going to see a lot of broader use
of foundation models in the soon nearby years.
Even though large language models have been
incredibly successful they don't really seem
to build the kind of world models that human
beings have where they have a sense of stuff in
a physical world and particular entities, human
beings and their relations that's more abstracted
away from particular sequences of words.
And so that suggests we need some kind of
different model of artificial intelligence.
But I think it's fair to say no one really knows
the answer of how to do that successfully and so
that's why we're still doing academic research.
AI system asks what are some of the most promising
and exciting real world applications of NLP
that you foresee emerging in the next few years?
Uh, tons! So I think we're going to see a lot
more NLP systems being deployed very successfully
everywhere. So a lot of websites already have
a little AI assistant in the bottom corner.
I think we're going to see a new generation
of ones powered by large language models
which really work much more fluently.
I think we're going to see much more
use of conversational assistants. So, you're
thinking about how to word an email to your
boss, or you're not quite sure what
you should say to your boyfriend.
It turns out that you can
get advice, drafting help,
suggestions of what to say from a large language
model that are actually useful these days.
You know, I think there's just a whole world
of ways that we can use these models because
our world is so language based and that we're
all just sort of exploring what some of thepossibilities are.
In the future will AI be so smart it won't need human input?
I think the honest answer is no one knows.
There is a conceivable world at some point in the
distant future where an AI system can just learn
everything it needs needs from the world around it
and it doesn't really need us to tell it things.
But I think there's also a lot of very heated
hype at the moment. Some people think that by
2030 there'll be computers that are better
than human beings at almost all tasks.
I think a lot of those views are fairly
irrational exuberance where people have
been getting a little bit too excited by
the very genuine big advances we made.
But there are other ways in which humans'
knowledge and ability to operate in the
world is likely to be better than our AI
models for a number of decades to come.
Will conversational assistants and
chat bots replace search engines?
I think there are different answers for
different kinds of searchers. So one
case is that people just have a particular
question in mind like "when is the primary
going to be held in the election for California."
To the extent that I've got a question like that,
yeah absolutely, conversational agents
LLMs are great for that sort of purpose,
then they're faster and better
than something else you could use.
You can also use them for all kinds of
other question-answering related purposes.
Sometimes people use search when they want
to take a deep dive themselves, right.
You know, they're buying a new tent and
they'd like to make up their own mind.
Then there's navigational queries
where they just want to be taken
to the page and that's obviously not
going to be covered by using a largelanguage model.
[Music]